now that we've uploaded a few screens
let's make a clickable prototype out of
them to do this simply click on any
screen within your project this will
bring us into the console mode the
console mode has four options at the
bottom preview build comet and history
mode for this section we'll only focus
on the preview and build mode click on
the build mode to begin creating
prototype hotspots in the build mode go
ahead and use your cursor and drag and
drop over an area of your image to
create the hotspot this will open a
window where you can choose the
destination for that hotspot you can
choose a gesture or a transition once
you've created that hotspot go ahead and
hit save and to preview whether or not
this interaction works I'm gonna go back
to the preview mode and there you have
it I've just created the very first
hotspot